hey there this is Alex car pause this
presentation director at Ubisoft
Montreal and this is every operator in
Rainbow six siege there's 50 of them so
buckle up alibi originally from Libya
now with GIS the Italian CTU most
operators in our game come from a CTU
that's a counter-terrorist unit
most nations have their own specialized
unit whether it's FBI SAT it's about
representing the elite of the elite
for your nation when you're representing
a CTU alibis strengths are confusion she
wants to make sure that nobody can lock
her down at any given time she's here
and then she's in another room using her
decoys are super important to make sure
that the attacking team doesn't have the
right information
that way she can jump and Surprise them
whenever she needs to and she can have
up to three of them on a map this
creates a lot of Intel because any
attacker that shoots through it will
actually get pinged and Alibi will know
where you're at I move from Peru who's
been introduced in operation amber arise
and she is with the APC a true is unlike
any operator we've had before she has a
grappling hook that lets her fly around
a map and this is the first time we're
tackling an operator that deals strictly
with movement it's actually a new way to
play the game we thought about a marui
about a year ago we called her our
attack on titan operator and the idea of
grappling around a map was something we
wanted to play with but it took a lot of
tech and research to make it work on
every single map that we had there are
so many challenges designing a marui
she's a person who can reach places
extremely quickly so we had to work on
how quick is her cool down on her gadget
and she's also somebody who latches on
to every single edge window so we had to
do a complete pass on every single map
to make sure that she didn't break
anything
ash FBI from the US of A ashes the de
facto leader of Rainbow six but
didn't actually plan it that way it all
came through her gameplay and how
players were perceiving her she was an
incredibly strong operator people always
promoted her into roles of importance
whenever they talked about her so she
kind of took on this mantle through the
community she was the first female
operator that we designed in the game
and we wanted to try to fit a bazooka
into the game and that was extremely
difficult when we talked to Nicola drily
a realization expert when it comes to
gadgets how do we get the effects of a
bazooka into a game like Rainbow six
siege and that's where you get Ash's
weapon bandit from Germany gsg-9 one of
our legacy operators the gsg-9
is a very casual unit all of them are
wearing jeans the idea was that they're
all these undercover operators so you
see bandit as this undercover biker gang
member in his elite outfit and that's
kind of the story behind it we wanted to
have a car battery that would Electrify
steel walls and it was kind of hard to
fit in the idea of a car battery with an
operator so we just called it a day
making him undercover with this car
battery electrified walls black beard
Navy SEALs from America black beard ifs
interesting because we learn so much
from his ability when he launched he was
one of the strongest overpowered
operators we ever released
besides the kick-ass beard of black
beard what I love is the story behind
the recruitment of the Navy SEALs
which obviously he's been through one of
the sessions that they have to go
through is what's called a surf training
where a bunch of seals link arms in the
ocean and have wave after wave crash
into their face and they have to do this
for eight to ten minutes it's a really
grueling test of physical strength and
mental strength blitz gsg-9 from Germany
a lot of people are terrified of blitz
the original idea for blitz though and
where he got his name from was even more
terrifying
while the defenders
reinforcing blitz actually spawns so
while you're pretty enforcing walls
there's this crazy blitz running around
the map at the same time blitzes biggest
strength is his speed and his ability to
disarm the other opponent so he uses his
shield flashbang them instantly run up
to their face and melee them it's really
really effective buck Canadian from the
GTF to buck is actually a bit of a
homage to our home studio in Quebec
he's very québécois when he grabs a
hostage he's like oh eh let's go and
it's a bit like in fring glitch he would
be saying oh eh on Eva and it's only
really funny
to prison game devs who think the
Quebecois accent is really cute Capitao
Bopha from brazil caputo is actually the
first operator with a disability he's
missing an eye and that wasn't to create
a weakness but to encourage showing the
strength that he has my favorite thing
about him was how long it took to get
the hair right caputo is one of our
oldest operators and so when you have
somebody in their mid 50s
how much gray hair do you put on that
head we had versions where he had too
much gray hair he looked like a guy who
did not belong on the battlefield and
then when there wasn't enough he looked
like a totally young dude running around
so balancing the gray hair level was
actually a big deal for us castle FBI us
of a castle used to be a pro football
player so you actually see a bit of that
in his silhouette as a large helmet
broad shoulders and he stands out from
the other FBI units castles strength is
being able to deny a lot of entry where
usually you can't these are windows
these are doors you can reinforce a wall
but it's harder to reinforce a window if
you have a castle you can put up those
barricades and now the attacking team
has to spend a lot more utility breaking
into a site cavada both pay from Brazil
Guevara is one of our more threatening
operators she's the only operator that
uses her ability
that's not reliant on a gadget and for
it we had to do some research
we watched documentaries about po'pay
interrogation sequences which are
absolutely brutal they're so so vicious
Bopha interrogation techniques can vary
from a knife to throat to waterboarding
to putting a bucket over your head and
beating it so what you see in the game
is actually a toned-down version of Bobe
interrogation and she has of course that
very unique face paint clash MPs from
England clashes our only defender with
the shield she's somebody who has a
threatening presence and shows a lot of
force behind that shield that she uses
the idea for clash was we had so many
operators on the attacking side with
shields could we do the same thing with
defenders and it came with a lot of
caveats it meant that she can't have her
shield and her weapon at the same time
so as an interesting balancing exercise
for a game design team my favorite thing
about her is how long it took to get
that shield right she has this giant
foldable shield that is transparent we
wanted that transparency so that
defenders could peek around see what
clashes seeing so that she could relay
information and then you can do
something about it
whenever you're rendering something with
transparency you're rendering two layers
one actual transparent layer and then
everything that's behind it and the
transparent layer has to affect
everything that's behind it so it's
actually really really costly to do and
that makes it hard when you have a giant
human size shield in front of an
operator duk-gi GN from France doc is a
medic so a lot of his being is in that
same vein he has the famous elastic
gloves he has a white stripe on his
helmet which signifies when he's in the
field and he also has his electric
paddles on him at all times he's
somebody who struggles with the idea of
taking a life
and he justifies it by saying if he
takes a life it's in order to save
others
Doc's strength is giving another player
a second chance he can at Rage rez
somebody if they're down but not out
and if you're long health ask your
doctor to heal you it can actually
change the tides of a battle
Doka be from the 707 from South Korea
Doka B is one of our greatest characters
she has so much characterization in her
she's the first operator to actually
smile in her portrait her name actually
comes from the Korean word for spirit
and it's a specific spirit that can
either play a prank or do some good so
when designing dhoka B this was the
first time where we created an operator
icon that wasn't tied to her gadget it's
the little dhoka B spirit and that's in
everything that she uses it's to
represent her it's on your phone when
she hacks you it represents who she is
and kind of like a mischievous way echo
SAT from Japan when designing echo we
kind of thought of the whole season when
we release skyscraper that was when we
were thinking okay how do we dress up
this unit and it's really about civilian
clothing underneath a lot of harnesses
that meant they could reach the
skyscraper map so the S IOT is the
counter-terrorist unit for Japan they
were first revealed in the 90s and a
little bit more info has been gathered
in the early 2000s when we reached out
to Japanese officials they didn't
provide us any information because the
SAT doesn't officially exist it meant
that we had to go through photography
items that we had to piece together it
was actually really difficult to know
what the CTU was about Ella from Grom
Poland ello was introduced in operation
blood orchid which was a bit of a
special season blood
orchid and she's a sister of Sophia in
the game and the two sisters play off of
each other very very differently
Ella after taking military academy went
to Berlin became an artist and that's
where she's really developed her
rebellious streak the Grom don't allow
you to dye your hair
so of course Ella dice her hair green
she kind of wears her own uniform that
she wants to wear pink from Spetsnaz
Russia
finca came in operation chimera and this
was around the same time that we
introduced the event outbreak the
outbreak event was a timed event where
an alien capsule actually landed there
and Rainbow six is called in to check it
out and that's where you see all of the
operators come in and fight off this
horde of zombies she has a rare DiNapoli
disease where essentially she loses
feeling in her extremities her ability
adrenaline batting that disease finca is
really knowing about your team her
adrenal surge actually means that recoil
is lessened which can actually throw off
your teammates sometimes so be
communicative make sure you tell them
hey I'm gonna be using my ability soon
let's go for us GT f2 from Canada so
when we were designing frost we gave
frost and but kind of the stereotypical
northerners heavy jackets she has her
two Khan which is the Canadian way of
saying winter hat and kitted her out so
that she could survive the elements
Frost is actually our first operator
that has a purely mechanical gadget
something that can't be detected by IQ
and we put a lot of work into her dorm
at Frost is door mat is something where
she lays down this bear trap device to
capture someone everybody looking at it
thinks it's immediately obvious that
there's something in front of them and
they'll get trapped in reality when
you're playing a game like siege though
you don't always look for things like
that and
it's one of those things where even in
pro level plays people will fall for it
fuse Spetsnaz originally from his Becca
Stein uses backstories actually pretty
dark it's based on the Moscow theater
hostage situation back in 2002 and this
is a theater that was full of 800 people
that the Spetsnaz could not breach so
what they thought they would do is they
would pump it full of gas that would
incapacitate everyone inside of it the
unfortunate thing was the gas was only
tested for external use and not interior
use so there was actually a lot of
casualties involved and that actually
translates to fuse where there can be
teammate casualties so it's pretty dark
but pretty true to the operator my
favorite thing about fuse is no matter
how confident the fuse is they'll
usually kill the hostage Blaz Spetsnaz
russian the inspiration behind glass is
actually the real Russian sniper Vassili
Zaitsev which you may have heard about
from enemy at the gates when we first
designed him he was a regular sniper and
nothing fancy about his weapon it was
only until his backstory of being an
artist and caring about details that we
introduced this element where he would
highlight the target through scope you
really don't have a lot of opportunities
of having that long range firefight so
you really have to know what long
corridors you have or what long line of
sites you have to make him really
effective
Goyo fes from Mexico Gao is one of the
more interesting operators we've
developed recently originally we wanted
him to be an alternative to smoke which
was to delay the attacking team and we
used the same mechanic as smoke as well
yet something that was throwable you
would throw a canister you would shoot
and then it would litter the floor in
fire the problem with that is there's so
much to think about and so much to do
that usually Goya would die in the
process of doing all that so we changed
it so that it was a deployable shield
where he would attach a canister behind
it and then anybody on his team could
trigger it and install an attacking team
gridlock SAS are from Australia when we
released gridlock in operation Burton
horizon we had a ton of feedback from
our Ubisoft Australia friends they gave
us names they told us what they would
say and what they wouldn't say and gave
a lot of feedback on their look as well
gridlock is this strong powerful
character who's at complete odds with
her partner who's mozzie one is the
strong silent type the other the little
annoying and won't shut up type during
the season that we launched them we tied
a lot of Easter eggs behind our
inspiration of Mad Max one of those
things was her middle name which is
various various is not Australian name
it's actually an anagram for furiosa
which is an homage to Mad Max Habana SAT
from Japan operation red crow an
interesting story about designing
Havana's gadget was that she has these
pellets that she launches and they have
to be very technical very quick and
deliver a payload that can open up an
area so we're actually struggling with
what does that look like how does it
behave our art director was working on
his motorcycle at the time and he pulled
off this piece that was kind of like a
sprocket and it became the Habana pellet
that we have in game IQ gsg-9
Germany the idea behind IQ and her
personality was actually taken from
Jodie Foster in Silence of the Lambs
when we were thinking about the
character it was all about this
intelligent individual that could
analyze people and was very very smart
in how she approached people jackal GE
Oh from Spain chuckles special ability
is to track footprints
on a map this is extremely powerful when
you're dealing with the team that has a
lot of roamers they're leaving a lot of
footprints on the exterior of their
defending area and it means that you can
pinpoint them a little bit more easily
and shut them down
Jaeger gsg-9 from Germany Jaeger
is our only pilot of the group he has a
pilot helmet which actually fits in
really well with the gsg-9 kits and it
was him who was flying the helicopter
during the outbreak event it goes down
and you have to go save him Caillou D
from GI gr from morocco tighted is our
oldest operator in the game so we wanted
somebody who kind of exuded strain but
also had a bit of a gun we just wanted
him to be this father figure of Rainbow
six no-nonsense very traditionalist from
design standpoint he became this
alternative to bandit where he could
Electrify a wall and deny a lot of entry
the whole idea behind kyod which
actually means commander is they're in
charge of a fortress whenever they are
the commander they have their own
special dagger and they get their own
new dagger each time a new commander is
responsible for the fortress kapkan
Spetsnaz from Russia not too many people
know this but his device is actually
filled with nails it's a bit harsh but
if you're running through a Capon device
the thing that explodes is a box full of
nails lesion SDU from hongkong lesion is
actually the only operator with short
son but it was actually a design we took
from a photograph of the CTU of somebody
walking around in cargo shorts and a
t-shirt holding a shield so it's based
off of the actual tire of the CTU unit
the toothpick that lesion has is
actually in reference to his spiky goo
mine it's also a reference to chow
yun-fat in Hong Kong adventure films
where he would always have a toothpick
or a matchstick then he would have
his Bell lion G IGN from France
the story of lion actually comes from a
French producer in Paris he grew up in a
very strict household attended military
academy and then dropped everything to
become a video game producer so that's a
bit of what you see in lines backstory
Lions special ability is his roar the
drone that flies in the sky and when he
triggers it everybody has to freeze
otherwise their position is gonna get
revealed he's the only attacker where if
a defender were to look out the window
at the sky they'd be like oh yeah
there's a lion coming against us we have
to deal with this now and the drone
itself is actually like a four meter in
diameter drone so it's huge
my Stroeve G is from Italy I joined the
team at the very start of Operation para
bellum and we started on this new
operator that has all this bravado he's
fearless he always has a smile I can
confirm that we took a little bit of
inspiration from a famous Italian
plumber for his look maverick Delta
Force American in operation grim sky we
actually had two operators from two
separate CTU's this was where we wanted
to focus more on backstories that were
really meaningful for them for maverick
he had gone to Afghanistan fell in love
with the culture and then disappeared
while maverick was in Afghanistan he
played busca XI this is a brutal brutal
sport where it's bit like polo but
instead of a ball it's a dead goat that
you play with our narrative director was
researching about Afghanistan its
culture actually found a French
journalist who much like maverick went
there fell in love with the culture and
actually discovered this sport that he
fell in love with and that kind of
raised a flag like this is amazing this
should be somebody's back
story Mira ge Oh from Spain Mira is
probably one of the most game-changing
operators when we released her in velvet
shell her one-way mirror meant that you
could gain a lot of information outside
of a defended room and it kind of
changed every single defense point in
the game for the attackers to kind of
adjust to this ability her gadget design
is actually based on military vehicles
so if a windshield of a military vehicle
would break and obstruct any kind of
vision there's a hydraulic that can
eject the window so that you can
continue driving and seeing where you're
going so this actually was the thinking
behind mirrors gadgets she's our
resident R&D specialist so almost every
gadget goes through her and so if we
need to make maybe a balancing change to
a gadget we attribute it to Mira making
these augmentations for these operators
montane G IGN from France
the idea behind Montaigne was the 1994
marine an assault where on a commercial
plane there was a hostage situation the
GI GN went in there using airplane
ladder to breach the airplane and rescue
the hostage at the front of that column
going up the steps
there was a GI GN officer and he took
grenade blasts he took shotgun shells
and he took bullets straight to the
chest and he would not stop and that
kind of embraces the look and feel of
montane Montagnes ability is a big-ass
shield when you're talking about a full
length shield like Montagnes ability
when it's activated you're the front
layer that separates the defenders from
the attackers and you're trying to relay
as much information as possible
mazi SAS are from Australia made mazi
brought a lot of energy to burnt horizon
he's the short energetic won't shut up
operator that
kind of keeps on yapping it's really
really really was like what mozzie is
actually based off of Robert Carlyle
from Trainspotting he's constantly being
bigger than who he is mouthing off and a
lot of that's reflected in mozzie
mute from the SAS Great Britain when the
team was thinking about Rainbow six
siege they're all fans of MOBAs but we
didn't know how that translated to the
operators in our game were they heroes
or were they more like a class and so
when you see mute and the SAS you can
see they all have those gasps Massa and
the only thing that differentiates mute
is two pieces of tape on his helmet
which is crazy because he's one of the
most recognizable operators in our game
mute is my favorite just because of
mystery that surrounds him he hasn't had
a face reveal yet so it'd be really cool
to see what that looks to be nuke your
corpse from Denmark nuke has a very
striking design she has this veil that
covers her face and it looks stunning
but when we tried it in the game we ran
into some problems mostly when you're
repelling a snook and you go upside down
that would mean that her veil would drop
and reveal her face which we cannot have
so we went back and actually attached
her veil two hooks on her armor only the
operators in Rainbow six know who she is
where she comes from
so you can see why it's really important
she's hiding that identity Nomad GI gr
from Morocco first of all this was an
operator where we didn't want to focus
on weapons when we're talking about her
we're talking about an explorer who's
gone to the highest heights and really
looked at everything that she could
travel around to visit write about in
her journal her losing digits on her
hand was to tell that she pushed past
obstacles like that so in all of her
weapons that she's holding and all of
the props that she's holding we have
to account for that when we're animating
her pulse
FBI American pulse is one of our
original operators and he was the only
operator that didn't have any kind of
headgear his look was based off of Bruce
Willis in die hard pulses strength is
gaining a lot of intel on the attacking
team knowing where they're coming from
and his kit helps him do all of this
it's amazing to see pulse uses gadget
which is the heartbeat sensor you can
see through the walls where the person's
heartbeat is and he can use c4 to
basically see them approaching on level
above throw the c-4 and explode it and
it's amazing whenever it pops off in a
pro league game rook G IGN French rook
is my favorite defender because he is
the most user-friendly operator in a
very complex game like Rainbow six siege
you have his ability which is
essentially dropping a duffel bag full
of armor for your teammates so the first
thing you do when you spawn is you drop
that duffle bag and your job's done
sledge SAS from the UK the original idea
of sledge comes from a real-life
operation
it was called Operation Nimrod it was
the assault on the Iranian embassy in
London the first person to breach the
embassy was a guy with a huge ass hammer
and that became sledge there's a lot of
video game magic that goes into the
timing of the swing of sledge how much
room he needs we wanted it to feel
impactful we also wanted you to see
everything so it took a bit of tweaking
with the animation and it's rather quick
sledge is pretty strong but I'm pretty
sure in real life would not be that
strong to be able to blow open a huge
hole in a reinforced wall smoke SAS from
the UK smoke is really special because
he was the very first operator design
for Rainbow six when we were talking
about smoke it came back to the idea
of well do we treat the entire CTU as a
unit
everybody gets um gas masks with the SAS
and we're thinking okay everybody has a
gas mask so they all share this kind of
visual do they share something that's
gameplay related to so we are initially
questioning whether or not all of the
SAS would be able to withstand smokes
ability or can see through smoke we move
more towards operators being heroes then
to something more like unit based this
is where we made a lot of design
decisions with smoke you don't really
have an idea of where his allegiance is
and actually smoke is a bit specific in
this respect and in this case it
actually helps that his face is hidden
to chunka Spetsnaz Russian when we
designed to chinco we didn't know
everything there was to know about
Rainbow six we still don't know
everything there is to know about
Rainbow six and how to play it but it's
a bit unfortunate that Rainbow six
always encourages movement never staying
in one place at any given time what that
means for tachanka his he has a gadget
where he's fixed in one place at any
given time it started out as a giant
mounted gun then we realized it was too
weak and we put a giant shield on it so
that he was a little bit more protected
when he's standing still for the other
team and it's still a little bit more
weak for him so we'll touch on to Gingka
maybe in another season
Thatcher SAS British Thatcher is
absolutely named after Margaret Thatcher
this ties in to sledge where he was part
of Operation Nimrod the assault on the
Iranian embassy in London if you search
Margaret Thatcher operation nimrod
you'll find a photo of Margaret Thatcher
standing with three SAS guys the guy in
the middle is Thatcher
that's why he's named after her on his
elite skin he actually has a medal from
Margaret Thatcher
for the operation there my FBI from
America thermite is absolutely one of my
favorite operators to play he's so
essential in a lot of the gameplay to
open up those areas of opportunity to
breach through and great open the shell
of defending team it was actually the
first time to where we had to think
about realizing the operator in a
first-person view so he has these
injured burnt hands that are bandaged
so we want to make sure that was an
important element when you're playing
him that you could see that we had to
work really hard on realizing the gadget
because nothing really exists like
thermite's breaching charge we had to
design it so that two explosions
happened one that separated the
reinforcement the second explosion was
when it pushed it in this was an example
of working on the realization working on
the animation where he places the charge
has to be very very careful setting it
up and then running for the hills and
triggering it twitch GI GN from friends
when we're designing operators we looked
at the CT use to inspire unfortunately
with the GI GM there had never been in
the history of GI GN a female operative
and this was actually an important
moment for Rainbow six where we decided
that it was more important to value
representation and diversity versus
basing it off of real life twitches
essentially the first female GI GN
operator
Valkyrie Navy SEALs American at the time
we were developing Valkyrie it was 2016
and that was actually a time when the
Navy SEALs opened up recruitment to more
than just males it was actually this
really cool opportunity to have this
super strong powerful female operator
for representing the Navy SEALs the
visual look of vel curry was heavily
inspired by kanessa Johnson a real army
vet that has these badass like sleeve
tattoos and really influenced the
of Valkyrie at the time felt special
ability is her vel cams this is a
throwable camera that you can throw onto
a wall under a chair anywhere really and
it acts as Intel for your team we
severely overestimated how much we can
control players and their creativity
when it came to this camera before we
patched it out the throw that bulk had
was incredible she was like a
quarterback if she broke open a window
and threw it it could fly across the map
and nobody would realize where the
camera was where they were being spotted
from so we had to adjust how strong
Valkyrie was when she was throwing those
cameras vigil 707 from South Korea
favorite thing about vigil has to be the
mask it's so iconic it's a bit inspired
by the 707 it was meant to be a bit
vague so that people could take away
what they wanted to it had to instill
fear but it also had to be a simple
enough mask that is it a hockey mask is
it like a threatening mask it's
something that anybody could look at and
kind of impart their own feelings on
warden u.s. Secret Service from America
this was a character that we wanted to
design for a long long time art director
wanted to have operator in a suit for
over two years and warden finally
presented himself as this perfect
embodiment of the slick agent in a suit
warden his ability is his smart glasses
he does a flashy little flip of a smart
watch and it triggers his glasses when
they're triggered he can see through
smoke which is really handy when it
comes to anybody who's thrown a smoke
and trying to plant on a cycle you SDU
from Hong Kong her special ability is
throwing a very unique flashbang you can
set it on a timer or you can set
so that it can go off immediately most
players throw as many as they can into a
room and then jump in but usually one of
her gadgets will do the job
Sofia Grom from Poland Sofia has an
interesting relationship with Ella her
sister in that they don't always get
along Sofia loves her sister but Ella
wants nothing to do with her and so you
have that kind of antagonistic
relationship and it actually bleeds over
into the game as well
if you kill Zofia with Ella you'll get
bonus points in the game Sofia is from a
more traditional military background
she's the first mother in Rainbow six
and this came from one of our developers
was pregnant and the writer was like
this is a super interesting element to
explore let's bring it in for the
backstory of Sofia Sofia has a very
unique ability that if she gets down but
not out she will revive herself with one
sliver of health it rarely rarely
happens but when it does it's epic
that's it for me everyone that's all 50
operators in Rainbow six siege I hope
you learned something from it see you
next time
you